[Music]
good evening and welcome to our debate
on language and power we're so happy to
have you
we tend to think that sharing experience
is essential to being human
at an individual level we share
experience to get to know others and
understand them we share political
experience to build community and
solidarity
yet from the taste of an apple to giving
birth we know we cannot fully describe
experience to someone who's not already
had it themselves
and many maintain that the experience of
discrimination can only be understood by
those who have experienced it
is the idea that we can understand the
experience of others the liberal fantasy
of a white male privileged elite
should authors limit their writing to
experiences they have undergone or which
fall within the realm of their culture
or is this a recipe for division and
conflict should we instead do all we can
to share experience and seek a common
language to understand each other and
the world
we have three brilliant humans to help
us think through these questions today
first john mcwhorter is an american
linguist and associate professor of
english and comparative literature at
columbia university he has written books
on both language and race including the
forthcoming nine nasty words english in
the gutter
and losing the race self-sabotage in
black america
cain d andrews is a british academic
author and activist and professor of
black studies at birmingham city
university
his latest release the new age of empire
how racism and colonialism still rule
the world came out in february of this
year
and l.a paul
is a professor of philosophy and
cognitive science at yale university
she's best known for her research on
transformative experience and her book
of the same name argues that we can know
very little about our subjective futures
so here we go
with our brief introductory pitches
three minutes each we'll start with kai
andy andrews and the question is
can we ever really understand the
experiences of others kai andy go for it
um hi good evening um
it depends where you are but hello
anyway and i think the key part of this
is really to i want to focus on the
power aspect of this um because language
is interesting but really this is the
whole issue here is the power and we we
can't we're not having this conversation
in a vacuum right
um can you understand the experiences i
guess in some theoretical realm
potentially we have to understand um
that you know there isn't just this
marketplace of ideas where everybody
comes to this equally we actually we're
in a place um an arena the places that
produce ideas and language and where
people can speak a deeply problematic
rooted in certainties of racism um and
deeply imbalanced right so when we're
even starting to have that conversation
um it is accomplished you have to really
understand the long history of the real
question here is who gets to speak who
gets to write um and that really is the
knob of this debate right for far too
long if you think about the ways that
you like britain etc um black and brown
creators have really been locked out
from that process so you haven't had as
many black and brown voices there in the
first place and not just locked out
accidentally locked out on purpose right
this is one of the ways
the racism works so we're not there
right i'll give you a concrete i said
and we like to think this has changed uh
dramatically but it really hasn't right
so if you think about publishing
industry today if you think about who is
the producers and as somebody who works
you know really does work a lot with
mainstream producers mainstream
publishers is you'll be very surprised
how wide it is right so there's all the
the voices you're making the decisions
are still still very still very um
narrow
um actually the book i wrote before this
book was called that black retailing
black radicalism from the 21st century
and the feedback i got from a major
publisher was it's too black like
literally that was a female it's too
black um and it just shows you the the
there's a kind of playing field right
there it is an equal right that has
particular norms and expectations
as well as they're not being black and
brown authors you've also seen that um
the way the black about people have been
represented has been hysteric
historically terrible these hack needs
stereotypes um flawed characters going
all the way back to othello right uh
coming through with ideas like the mammy
and the matriarch and terrible movies
like gone with the wind etc but again
look at today's not that much better the
idea of the black the hoodlum um the
really narrow roles that uh black women
still operate in the in in the
mainstream media and television et
cetera and and in and in literature so
when we're having this question about
can people represent it's the wrong
question is can we trust the
institutions we're trusting to represent
their people and around people
effectively i think the answer is no
right and we have to again it really is
about saying we we we have a discourse a
public discourse a we have a
way of producing ideas which is really
distorted by historical illusions and
myths right which isn't an equal playing
field it does which doesn't always which
you know you can have great
representation but it's almost the
the
when you do it's almost kind of this
stands out right because it's terrible
um and so i want to kind of the final
point i make is that it is this kind of
liberal idea that we don't want division
we just want if you cannot if you can
get the other people to understand you
this is what we this is what is the
solution this is complete nonsense i
mean we've been on the right side of the
argument for 500 years this is not going
to be good right like is it
isn't the case that we haven't tried to
make these arguments it's the fact that
when you try to make these arguments you
find you end up talking around in
circles or oftentimes talking to
yourself and the honest truth is that
division is rooted into the system that
we have
um and the idea that we just all need to
come home together and hold hands and
then and share experiences as the
business solution is really not the case
actually a bit more confident
thank you so much john how do you
respond to this admittedly flawed
question um can we ever really
understand the experiences of others
please
i
understand but i i find
what he's saying
to correspond more gracefully to a
present tense analysis than thinking
about how history proceeds and history
unfortunately proceeds slowly that's the
problem revolutions are rare and usually
and usually don't work and so my brief
answer to the question
is that for one thing there are three
things one thing is that i worry that
this is the question that we ask so very
very much when we talk about
understanding if somebody from 50 years
ago listened to a question about us
understanding each other they would
almost be perplexed that our spontaneous
impulse today
is to assume that the question really
refers to that of oppression and
it's not that oppression isn't real but
we're to assume that the most
interesting thing the most urgent thing
the most important thing to address
about human relations especially in
stratified societies is who is
oppressing who and whether or not the
oppressor can understand the perspective
of the oppressed now it's not that
that's a meaningless topic and it's not
that there is an injustice in the world
but that is one
of what i would venture is several dozen
facets of what it is to be human what it
is to be a human society and i think
that the way we're encouraged to look at
it ends up being a minimization not of
what it is to be and let's face it white
it's a minimization also what it is to
be brown or something else oppression is
real
it is not the defining experience of all
people who are not white to the extent
that especially we have been told in a
mainstreamed way since roughly june of
last year second
i am
worried that
we're saying that white people don't
understand without thinking about how
much less they understood as recently as
25 or 30 years ago i see great progress
on this with all due respect today i
don't
go through life myself thinking of
whites as
if i may as obtuse as you're implying
that we just keep beating our heads
against the ball it feels to me as if
teachers i knew when i was say five
years old going back 50 years at this
point really were quite clueless
compared to roughly anybody who was
allowed anywhere near a student today
for example i think that slowly society
is acquiring an understanding of how the
person below feels that is unprecedented
in the history of the species three
hundred thousand years of homo sapiens
name any other time when the rulers are
capable of even pretending to understand
what they do to those down below to the
extent that today's intelligentsia and
frankly even many not intelligentsia
people do i think that history is moving
along and very briefly third i think
that um
when we have this particular
sense of oppression there's an
unfortunate thing that happens because
of social history where many people not
all
i wouldn't even say most but there is an
encouragement of those of us who are
down below to exaggerate i hate to say
this but to fabricate to suppose that
this kind of being misunderstood is the
essence or the most important thing
about being for example black and when
somebody does that they're not being
deliberately manipulative i'm not
calling anybody a snowflake either but
this happens it happens more than we
like to think i don't like mentioning it
but the way we talk about this
encourages a lot of black young people
to think that the most interesting thing
about them is their victimhood and i
find that diminishing not of white
people i'm not defending white people
here i find it diminishing of people of
color to focus on it in the way that we
do i think that we need to change
dialogue somewhat
thank you so much and laurie um over to
you
the question the invitation here is to
respond to the question can we ever
really understand the experiences of
others
well like a good philosopher i'm going
to say
yes and no
so i'll start with no um and to see why
uh i think the answer is no
i'll quote alex huxley
he says we live together we act on and
react to one another but always and in
all circumstances we are by ourselves
we can pull information about
experiences
but never the experiences themselves
from family to nation
every group is a society of island
universes
now this is about the problem of other
minds
so in a certain way
the answer is no we can't ever really
understand the experiences of others
because we're all fundamentally alone in
a disturbing way
but in another sense i think there's
hope
that comes when
we have experiences that are similar
to the experiences of others right and
hopefully with empathy
and epistemic humility we can attempt to
try to understand something about the
experiences of others but
i don't want to be too optimistic about
this for just the reasons that have been
sort of outlined by uh john already
because when
people
have had very different kinds of
experiences those of us who haven't had
those kinds of experiences
lack access
into the distinctive nature of that
lived experience without living that
kind of experience ourselves we should
not pretend that we have the ability to
understand the nature of that experience
instead we need to step back and listen
and respect the fact that sometimes
people have experiences and
live their lives
in contexts that are foreign to those of
us who live our lives in another a
different kind of context and so in
order to fully understand their
experience we'd have to project
ourselves into their lived experience
and have that experience for ourselves
and that just may not be possible
so
we need to recognize that and i think
one job
of a white person like myself is to
listen and to understand that there are
things that maybe i can't know
and to respect that and to respect the
testimony of somebody who's had a
different kind of life experience than
i've had
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you